you over in the lab looking at yellow
with blue obviously the clutching your
brow clutch here our family member but
not your father this that is hmm six
months on and he's six months on it I'm
dick you [ __ ] no Clara who's Clara three
Klis it you and the big I can tell by
the yellow markings on your left
shoulder that you I can tell by the old
markings on your shirt sleeve that you
had a sandwich for lunch messy mustard
Ellie
haha you are a vegetarian not a
vegetarian see in your eyes a vitamin
b12 deficiency the vitamin most easily
found in meat explain it you can't
explain cuz you're vegetarian
homeschooled London central heavy smoker
two packs a day
never in my life heterosexual bicurious
put your dick in a [ __ ] and it feels so
good that's true kids again that's right
if you're sound again but your dad left
your mum there very happily married
married happily 60 years
your dad is 50 in the p-side I'll give
you that one
hahaha mark how could you possibly know
anything about me your [ __ ]